is because the supreme court nominee i
don't know if we picked this but she got
confirmed let me ask you a question
are there candles being lit in the
stefano home
for the supreme court who has been
confirmed
yeah they're confirmed are because you
know
i i will say what it is this is a great
victory for the unborn
yeah it's a great victory for the unborn
i will say this
you there's a house in ridgewood there's
a house in ridgewood on that night that
you got you got there's two words
happy campers
because do you think uh yeah i mean that
we got we got real white walkers i think
her getting confirmed is the sorcery
that was needed
to summon up the army of the dead
remember like games of thrones yeah
and they're gonna come and try to try to
topple donny t's wall the only problem
is they're very little because
so you can really just kick them because
they you know they never got a chance to
really grow
so it's gonna be a war that we can win i
believe it's what it is there's a lot of
people upset that they can't kill their
babies i mean what can you do
what can you do because that's what
you're doing at the end of the day
at the end of the day that's what it is
but i understand is blah blah blah
ladies fellas we know we know men have
uteruses we know
i i don't [ __ ] care anymore she's a
confirmed so
she's the supreme court justice just
[ __ ] deal with it okay like
everything else in life
just suck it up and [ __ ] deal with it
if trump becomes president again just
deal with it okay we all don't like him
we all know that supreme court justice
is swayed republican just [ __ ] deal
with it okay
your vote doesn't matter your protest
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
just shut up and deal with it and buy
tickets at history iheanas.com
there you go a little steel pipe chrissy
he because you're doing
more outfit changes than madonna this
episode because
it's yeah it's fun it's just my audition
tape for snl
and let's just say i just want to stay
here now i just want to say
i want to bow down and say rbg thank you
for being a hero
thank you so much for your service to
your country as a feminist icon and a
strong warrior princess
and i just want to say when obama asked
you
when he went to lunch and he said hey
you've had cancer for the 80th time
you're in your 80s um do you want to
think about maybe retiring so
i can replace you and you said uh
uh girl power we're gonna keep going
all the way and really run the rest and
she
kept going and you know it's funny she
almost made it
he only had like a month left but then
she dropped so just
thank you rbg for not retiring and being
a boss [ __ ] and dying so then a
republican president
could put in someone who who wants to
keep those aborted babies alive
thank you and give it up for rbg aka
james altucher
um there you go here we go watching hope
you enjoyed the last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]
oh